ces deux petits jetons prouve que j'ai
réussi les deux premiers casse tête de
cette série à savoir c'était le fouet le
cavalier il ya quinze jours vous avez la
vidéo juste ici et j'ai toujours pas
reçu le pion et aujourd'hui on va
essayer de résoudre un maximum de ces
trois peut-être un des 3 2 des 3 3 des
trois on ne sait pas je sais que suis en
train de faire quelques déçus à qui
attend mon intro habituel de youtube
heures mais j'ai plus l'idée depuis que
je fais ça depuis fin juin gp l'idée
alors mettez moi dans les commentaires
les intros de youtube heures que vous
aimeriez que je reprenne et on fera ça
pour les prochaines vidéos partir de la
semaine prochaine ou en octobre avant de
commencer cette tour cette magnifique
tour ils sont ils sont vraiment très
stylé un partant de toute cette série je
pense que après je les mettrai dans le
décor je fais un échec et un truc je
disais donc avant de commencer cette
tour nous allons nous attarder un
endroit très précis qui ce sont les
centaines de messages que je reçois
chaque jour sur les différents réseaux
sociaux toi même tu sais instagram en
priorité et puis aussi par mail et dans
les commentaires des vidéos vous me
demandez si je passe en spectacle dans
telle ville ou dans telle ville
souvent c'est oui et j'ai vraiment
l'impression pourtant d'être sous laon à
vous répéter en permanence que sur le
site il ya la carte de la tournée d'un
coup d'oeil vous pouvez voir il ya même
un moteur de recherche qu'on a codé avec
un pote qui s'appelle aymeric avec nos
petits doigts pour vous puissiez taper
le nom de votre ville et mon site vous
dis dans un rayon de 60 km si je viens
jouer par chez vous le nouveau spectacle
de singularité qui est à l'olympia mais
c'est déjà complet aussi à la fin du
mois alors vraiment si vous vous posez
la question à lecce cayla serait la
réponse
et après il ya également d'autres villes
qui reviendront donc n'hésitez pas à les
check et de temps en temps et les autres
villes je les annoncerai de temps en
temps et oui vraiment la belgique ça va
arriver
c'était un peu compliqué à mettre en
place mais les belges j'arrive par chez
vous mais par exemple la semaine
prochaine je serai à ergué gabéric la
semaine d'après je serai à nantes à
amiens en dédicace et puis ensuite un
spectacle à lyon au radiant bref toutes
les villes arrivent
n'hésitez pas je dis pas le jarret en
ligue 1 c'est parti
la tour la tour mon gars alors cette
tour comme vous pouvez le constater via
cette caméra qu'on a mis ici parce que
nous sommes des petits malins elle peut
bouger par le bas comme ça
lâchés en train de bouger toute cette
partie là jusqu'à cette limite
elle peut aussi bouger par le haut comme
ceux ci mais un petit peu on sent que
c'est bloqué et l'aspect risque qui est
ici peu bougé d'une manière complètement
indépendante
c'est tout ce qu'on sait il ya plus de
trucs qui bougent alors je m'en réfère à
ce que j'ai vécu avec le cavalier par
exemple que je dois encore capable
d'ouvrir
voilà comme ceux ci il y avait une
encoche et un petit trou pour aller dans
l'encoche il y avait également un petit
toutou you say is to say this war comme
daisy qui est maintenant bloqué
évidemment il faut que je le développe
en faisant ça on a retrouvé cette même
config au final dans le fou je pense
qu'on va retrouver sa dans la tour en
tout cas c'est ce que je j'aime
ré-imaginer mais à chaque fois
l'intérieur ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur et qu'on voit pas ne sais
pas comment c'est fait c'est très très
ingénieux vous avez le lien dans la
description verser 4 d'être là ils sont
très très cool
alors bon celui-ci par le aulas est
complètement de look et ça ça tourne et
je croyais que ça bougeait ici mais dont
je suis le pire je sais pas comment on
pourrait dire en français solveur de
casse-tête du monde depuis tout à
l'heure vous me voyez faire ça là quand
je dis septembre par le bas fait
s'attendent pas du tout il ya mes doigts
qui transpire un peu et du coup glisse
sur la paroi est lancé ça tombe pas
arrête cette petite musique lake donc il
ya que le haut qui tente ça qui bougent
un peu et ça doit être ça qui doit être
bloqué quelque part et lui qui bougent
un peu quand on a résolu clou on l'a eue
avec un truc un peu en diagonale et
s'était penché en fait et c'est comme le
déplacement alors la tourelle elle bouge
en ligne droite
du coup je commençais à essayer des
petites choses comme ça du coup la
techniquement ça ne fait rien du tout
[Musique]
j'essaie de bouger ça aussi à jann * qui
est bloqué non ce serait trop stylé de
d'avoir dans toutes les pièces
alors là on les a en métal il faudrait
aussi un métal noir elle se faire une
vraie partie d'échecs avec ça et pas
pour des places et on pion au genre ou
alors si quelqu'un mange champions il
peut être capable de le résoudre pour le
tuer sinon ils restent sur la touche pas
faire des règles de d'échec alternatif
me loïc me chuchote que ce serait long
la partie ben ouais mon gars il y avait
un jeu je suis pas ce type connus ou si
vous connaissez dites moi si vous êtes
de joie ça qui s'appelait tampon sur un
échiquier et c'était génial c'est un jeu
de cartes que d'associer un jeu d'échecs
et il y avait juste besoin de connaître
le déplacement de base des pièces échec
donc ça s'apprend très vite et ensuite
n'importe qui pouvait gagner je dirais
un très nul contre un grand maître
pouvait gagner parce que les cartes qui
intervenait qui veut faisait faire
n'importe quoi genre un moment donné
le roi le roi devient fou et se
maquillant rennes et d'un coup on peut
faire n'importe quoi
il y avait plein plein plein de 2,2 de
règles comme ça à chaque fois que tu
joues tu vous intervenez un kart
peut-être même que loïc va trouver la
boîte du jeu et s'il la trouve
je vous mets un sondage ici et vous me
dites si ça vous dit qu'un jour je fasse
une partie genre contre absolvent qui
joue très bien aux échecs bien mieux que
moi je vous le dit eh bien on pourrait
équilibrer les forces avec tempête sur
un échiquier séparément ce geste on
pense le hic c'est pour être mince ce
qu'ils nous ont fait dédé
je vous promets que c'est pas fait
exprès en jeu il ya un truc qui s'est
débloquée là j'arrive à dévisser le
passé c'est marrant ça c'est marrant
parce que au au hockey on se calme tout
de suite pourquoi je veux dire pourquoi
puisque justin discutant et en
manipulant je crois que j'ai résolu le
casse tête puisque maintenant j'ai
libéré il ya un petit pièce mais
j'arrive pas la sortir je crois qu'elle
est faible au delà voyez là vous l'avez
l'avoir ici en fait juste allez allez
allez allez bloqués en bas à gauche pas
du tout d'accord avec ce jeu ces
concepts tin tin tin tin tin tin tin tin
tin tin tin tin tin tin tin tin tin
qu'est ce qui prouve pourquoi débloquer
c'est nul ils ont mis une pièce qui
s'est bloqué c'est pas moi c'est ma
récompense pour avoir ouvert avec une
réflexion très poussé un d'ailleurs pas
se mentir
donc il va falloir que je sois capable
de reproduire ce que j'aime faire dans
le comprenant souci alors là le beats
audio que vous voyez ici
en fait ils sincères et là ce qui fait
qu'au départ je pouvais pas dévissé on
est bien d'accord
donc comme il est comme ça c'est
forcément en retournant qu'il est rentré
à l'intérieur et que j'ai pu commencé à
dévisser donc je vais rester comme ça je
vais bouger d'astérix pour voir ce qui
se passe
ah bah oui d'accord ok ok et en fait si
je fais ça il ressort
d'accord c'était assez simple en fait
assez simple aulika soit honnête c'était
là ça me paraît simple parce que je vois
en fait exactement ce qui est en train
de se passer là à la base il aurait
fallu que je le devine mais là le by
tonio est sorti donc ils rentreraient
dedans et en tournant l'astérisque un
moment donné je peux le faire rentrer et
quand il est rentré je sens ici de ce
côté là que sa force un petit peu et
c'est sous d'affaires que je peux viser
ça veut dire que si je fais ça comme ça
et que je fais ça
un matin il s'était pas bien passé parce
que là je peux toujours away attend
s'est chopé un truc qui est pas du tout
logique en fait dans ce casse tête
comment on peut être sûr ans revit sens
que je vais être au bon endroit puisque
je veux dire ou pas a peut-être que
c'est une daube
le jeu vous et je vous explique éléments
problème ici un trou qui vient
accueillir en réalité le petit bitonio
quand il est ressorti
parce que là c'est clair là je le faire
rentrer ses géants mais comme il n'y a
pas un vrai début à une vis je peux
commencer un peu où je veux je sais pas
si le moment où je vais arriver au bout
le petit bitonio va se mettre
directement là où il faut vous comprenez
où c'est vraiment un peu bête ce que je
dis je veux vraiment je vous entends pas
des fois j'ai envie de vous soyez tous
là dans le bureau avec moi entre un père
le casse-tête à la en fait j'ai essayé
de viser au départ que ce soit en face
et j'ai tourné là effectivement c'est
bloqué donc si je fais ça il faut quand
même
oui non j'y arrive pas mais non c'est
pas bloqué a c'est ma déception à a1 a6
ayé c'est bon il est bloqué attends je
sais plus si je suis déçu et ce que je
suis pas déçu mais également de l'eia ok
si en visant bien au départ ça se
remettaient sinon c'était vraiment
dommage quoi donc là ça tourne quand lui
amovible cercle bitonio sortie je peux
pas je ne peux toujours pas et si après
je bouge uniquement l'astérisque par en
dessous donc ça vous pouvez pas le voir
je vais faire en sorte qu'à un moment
donné le bitonio ce bloc
celle d'être le cas donc là il doit être
redescendue ce qui veut dire que je peux
davis et qui exactement
et c'est ça qui s'est passé quand je te
parlais tout à l'heure sympa évidemment
je ne trouve pas ou fait peut-être que
vous non plus mais parce que comme j'ai
ouvert par hasard après j'ai pu regarder
exactement quelle était la mécanique est
forcément mais c'est encore une fois un
biais qui fait que j'ai l'impression
d'être supérieur à ce casse tête et
qu'en fait il n'était pas digne de moi
alors que pas du tout j'ai juste eu un
gros coup de bol au départ et après
c'est suite à ce coup de bol que j'ai pu
voir le truc de l'intérieur et
comprendre le fonctionnement donc
forcément c'est pas non plus on va voilà
là je les rebloquer c'est bon et j'ai
pas sorti la petite pièce parce que je
pense qu'elle est bloqué j'ai pas envie
de l'abîmé plus que ça cette vidéo me
paraît bien assez longue non donc je ne
ferai pas un deuxième casse tête ça veut
dire qu'il reste encore deux ou trois de
cette série à faire peut-être en une
vidéo peut-être encore en deux je sais
pas mais donc on verra ça pas la semaine
prochaine celle d'après directement en
octobre en attendant toujours les
petites vidéos bonus sur la chaîne se
sent un peu n'importe quand ça peuvent
pour sa foi et abonnés faut être
vigilant faute elle écoute fait hum
ouais ok j'adore les échecs dans 20 ans
y en a plus à très bientôt ciao